bonsoir rené georges querry merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur ft france
alors ces dernières années l'union
européenne a beaucoup développé la
surveillance de ses frontières et a
notamment partagé ses informations entre
les états membres
mais on le voit cela ne suffit pas pour
endiguer la menace terroriste
tout d'abord la menace terroriste telle
qu'elle existe depuis maintenant cinq
ans six ans est d'abord et surtout
endogène elle a été réalisée certes par
des gens de sont venus de l'extérieur
le bataclan on a vu et aussi ces
derniers trois derniers attentats ont
été commis par des immigrés mais
globalement c'est au sein des pays que
naissent et se développent cette menace
que c'est de ce risque terroriste
mais il est vrai qu'il faut renforcer
les frontières alors le problème
évidemment de ne pas faire une
assimilation un peu facile entre
immigration et terrorisme tous les
immigrés ne sont pas des terroristes
hélas et troisième les terroristes
étaient des immigrés mais je crois
surtout que la priorité c'est de lutter
contre l'immigration mais qui doit être
une action malgré taux différencié de la
lutte contre le terrorisme alors la
différencier compliqué puisque les
personnes se sont présentées comme des
comme des migrants ils ont même pour
certains ont obtenu l'asile
comment faire pour la différencier selon
vous c'est très compliqué surtout s'il
n'y a pas de passif sur ces personnes
non c'est effectivement très compliqué
c'est un ris avec un risque avec lequel
nous devons vivre mais je crois surtout
que parmi les annonces qui ont été
faites
'l'annonce la plus importante est celle
qui concerne la maîtrise des
informations tout ce qui est un citation
la haine
on a vu dans la sphère de l'assassinât
de bâti de samuel pâtit que une fatwa
avait quasiment été lancée sur internet
pour être perçu 80 km plus loin pas un
tchétchène qui est venu assassiné ce
professeur je pense que un des points
importants sur lequel l'union européenne
viennent travailler et qui doit être
mise en oeuvre
c'est fait
de mieux maîtriser éventuellement couper
toutes les informations qui concernent
l'apologie l'incitation à la haine ne
sera pas attentatoire aux libertés
individuelles
parce que la première des libertés c'est
de ne pas être assassiné faire retirer
justement les contenus à caractère
terroriste dans l'eure c'est ce que veut
l'union européenne est ce que cela vous
paraît faisable
ça ça demande aussi la contribution des
gaffes un bon mois les gaffes a
normalement il doit faire son lot de
noeuds ce qu'on leur dit de faire
c'est l'état qui doit maîtriser le
dispositif
une députée avait tenté une projet de
loi en juin dernier qui a été cassée par
le conseil constitutionnel où il
s'agissait effectivement d'aller un
petit peu maîtrisé cette information à
écouter faut savoir ce que l'on veut
c'est toujours l'éternel problème entre
la sécurité des gens la liberté
d'information mais là il s'agit de
d'éviter de diffuser du venin sur la
toile je pense qu'il n'y a pas
d'atteinte aux libertés individuelles
comment améliorer également la
surveillance des frontières extérieures
de schengen ce qui voudrait dire qu'à
l'intérieur on peut circuler comme on
veut ça demande quel effort
supplémentaire
il y à déjà frontex qui le fait mais
comment améliorer les frontières
extérieures selon vous de l'union
européenne
oui alors ça c'est effectivement un
problème énorme
on est toujours dans des logis
technocratique on parle de front traict
frontex les frontières extérieures
si vous regardez la carte européenne de
schengen ça représente quasiment tous
les pays de l'union de l'europe de
l'ouest à l'exception de l'angleterre
est aujourd'hui des balkans
c'est quand même énorme qu'il s'agit des
frontières terrestres qu'il s'agisse des
frontières maritimes
on voit bien tous ces clandestins qui
essaient d'arriver en italie au risque
de au péril de leur vie les frontières
alors dans les aéroports ça marche
plutôt bien parce qu'il ya un passage
obligé un contrôle auquel il est
difficile de se soustraire
mais après c'est tout le problème des
frontières terrestres et maritimes
et effectivement je pense que là
n'est pas encore sorti de l'auberge pour
le contrôle des frontières terrestres et
maritimes
quand ça le partage des informations qui
se fait déjà beaucoup entre les 27 pays
membres est ce que cela vous paraît
suffisant ou faut-il renforcer aussi cet
aspect là alors je pense ou l'ordre déjà
le premier point qu'en france on est
vraiment dans une situation de smos
notamment entre la dgse la dgsi
l'interview vaujourd'hui de bernard emié
de nicolas lerner dans un grand
quotidien montre bien qu'en france
franchement on joue collectif comme
aurait dit aimé jacquet et on est
vraiment dans une bonne cohérence dans
une bonne cohésion
après à l'échelon européenne c'est peut
être un peu plus compliqué chaque pays a
son propre fichier
chaque pays a sa propre technique sa
propre technologie
la fluidité n'est peut-être pas aussi le
forte qu'on pourrait l'imaginer surtout
content qu'on pourrait le souhaiter
alors là il y aura probablement des
efforts à faire mais c'est plus hamon
avait une question de technologie
d'harmonisation la technique entre les
différents fichiers que de volonté la
volonté politique elle existe et
croyez-moi relation européen elle existe
déjà depuis 30 ans notamment à l'époque
ont déjà longue lutte et déjà contre
contre ce que l'on appelait leur
terrorisme la volonté européenne existe
vous dit
existe-t-elle vraiment lorsqu'il s'agit
de d'opérations extérieures comme c'est
le cas notamment de l'implication de la
france au mali
est ce que la volonté existe aussi à ce
niveau là de contrer sur le terrain les
terroristes alors là c'est un autre
sujet si effectivement il ya une volonté
européenne réel pour protéger le
territoire néo et les citoyens aux pme
cit citoyenneté européenne est de
protéger les gens sur le territoire
européen
à l'étranger c'est différent n'a pas
encore une diplomatie européenne n'a pas
encore une armée européenne et il est
évident que sur ce plan là à mes yeux je
suis pas un grand spécialiste des
questions internationales mais je pense
que la france qui s'engage avec courage
et détermination au moyen-orient et en
afrique pour justement maîtrise et
essayer de contrôler la montée de
l'islamisme dans ces pays là en sachant
que ça peut déborder sur l'europe et
bien
je le dis la france je la trouve bien
seul dans ce combat
merci beaucoup rené georges querry
d'avoir répondu ce soir en direct à nos
questions sur rtl france